I'm surprised that you weren't surprised
because because well we're hopeful the
government had him dead to rights
because he had admitted to what he did
there was plenty of evidence and the
government was pushing to make him an
example why didn't that work big if John
has a great story you know he he didn't
accept the money for himself it went to
the program it helped his students and
the sailors in fact the university still
have the money they haven't returned it
yet none of the students that he engaged
singer with even applied to Stanford
so forget about not being admitted they
never applied so there's no other
student out there who applied to
Stanford didn't get in because of
something John did and John has a
compelling life story he really is a
great guy no criminal record before this
was well-respected in the failing
community and frankly he's done well
even since this happened he pled guilty
he got fired he lost everything his home
his car his health insurance his income
and he's rebounded so what a lot of
people want to know is is this kind of
quid pro quo so common in the education
system that he just thought this is the
way things are done and I'm just gonna
go along I don't know I don't think he
thought that I think he did feel some
pressure probably to raise money for a
program I think a lot of people in
college athletics feel that but I think
what happened is he got on a slippery
slope with Ric singer and singer pushed
it and pushed it and it got to a place
where they broke the law